in november of 1983 the demogorgon was
banished from hawkins and during
christmas of that year 12 year old
william byers coughed up a strange slug
that disappeared down the drain of his
sink the creatures of the upside down
would not be finished with this small
town quite yet a new form of the
demogorgon coined as the dummy dog has
been growing its ranks in the shadows
because the demidogs operate using a
hive mind they're able to dig a series
of tunnels underneath the town despite
their mental connection one of them
manages to distance itself from the rest
of the pack and even form a bond with
one of the humans to dive into the hive
and see how the demogorgons pack really
works and what made d'artagnan an
occasional exception stick around to the
end of this video this video is
sponsored by scentbird
[Music]
it's halloween in 1984 and the kids of
hawkins indiana are not missing out on
their trick-or-treating but 13 year old
dustin henderson finds the most
surprising treat of the night in his
trash can foraging for food after
bringing the small slimy creature inside
he believes he's discovered a species of
polywog a tadpole that he expects to
grow into some kind of amphibian i'll
call this stage 1 of the creature's
metamorphosis and just for fun i'll give
it a nickname the demewog physically it
looks like a slimy frog with an extended
tail he tries feeding at a few pieces of
his three musketeers bar and discovers
that the creature doesn't like the heat
lamp in the tortoise tank that he's
keeping it in it hides in the shade
until dustin turns the heat lamp off at
which point it goes to munch on the
candy because it takes a liking to this
chocolate bar dustin names it d'artagnan
after the protagonist of the three
musketeers novel on dartanyang but
mostly just refers to it as dart for
short we don't know if dart is male or
female or if it just doesn't have a
gender like mewtwo but dustin seems to
think it's a dude i got you little guy
it's not yet known if this is a result
of digesting the chocolate or part of
its metamorphosis but that evening dart
has some kind of violent stomachache
that includes something moving around in
its abdomen if you can call it that that
causes it to screech out in pain
dustin brings dart to school the next
day thursday november 1st and his
homemade ghostbusters track and
convinces his friends to join him in the
av room to see his discovery during
class dart rumbles around in its case
and makes noises reminiscent of a
stomach growl that afternoon everyone
takes a turn holding dart oh he's like a
living booger i say the same thing every
time someone touches me in l.a they
theorize that dart is a polywog but he
only seems to resemble species from
india and south america mike notices
what looks to be something moving around
inside of it and moves the light to get
a better look dart doesn't appreciate
the direct light and freaks out the
sound of the screech he makes causes
will to remember the upside down and the
moment he spit out a potentially smaller
version of dart a year ago unlike the
known species of polywog which are cold
blooded dart doesn't like light or heat
so believing he discovered a new species
dustin and the group decided to show
their science teacher mr clark however
after will reveals to mike that he
believes dart is from the upside down
they rush to stop dustin before he gets
mr clark involved since they made a pact
with the hawkins lab the previous year
that they'd keep all the stuff about the
upside down a secret they quickly bring
the container back to the av room dart
rages inside of the box causing the
whole thing to shake violently mike
readies a heavy microphone in case it
attacks and dustin releases the dorms
instead of attacking it screeches while
its skin ripples a pair of hind legs
bursts from its sides with the
spattering of slime
it would appear that the agonizing
sounds it had been making had less to do
with it being hungry and more to do with
growing pains from the metamorphosis the
movement they had seen around its
abdomen area was most likely the
creature trying to kick out its timed
legs and be able to move more
effectively we'll call this stage 2 the
demo frog dart runs out of the door and
away from the danger it sensed in the
room then dustin tackles his friend max
for no reason lol dart ends up hiding in
the back corner of a bathroom stall will
finds it first but darth's screeching
gives will a little upside down ptsd
once the door shuts dart moves behind
the toilet until dustin arrives doing
his best randall boggs
it would appear that dustin was right
about the trust shared between himself
and dart because when he finds him dart
is willing to hop into dustin's hands
and ride under his hat after being
returned to the safety of dustin's
turtle tank dart goes to town and some
more three musketeers before falling
asleep for the night deciding dart would
be safer at home dustin leaves him in
the turtle tank while he goes to school
the next day now either dustin didn't
see gremlins or he forgot the rules
about feeding strange creatures late at
night because he returns home to find
the tank broken with some kind of molted
skin or membrane dripping in slime left
inside it's strange that dustin doesn't
seem to notice the immediate parallels
between his own situation with darts and
what goes on with gizmo the titular
gremlin of gremlins late at night maybe
he somehow missed gremlins being in
theaters back in august because he went
away to camp during the summer or he let
his joy over discovering a slimy new
friend cloud his judgment dart grows
into stage three the demahog not because
it looks like a hog but more because
he's hogging up all the food like
dustin's cat will and mike had
previously shared their worries about
dart being a creature from the upside
down and this is basically confirmed
here when dart's face opens up like the
demigorgon from a year ago canine teeth
included and this is also confirmed by
the vfx team of the show the maturation
rate of dark quickly shows how the
demidogs can increase their numbers by
using a bolting process that may or may
not be sped up by eating certain foods
perhaps dustin realizes that as he comes
up with a plan to trap darts using a
classic trail of bologna slices he lures
the creature outside and beats him into
the cellar that could have gone so badly
what gives you the right what's the
difference between you and me i'm not
wearing hockey pads what makes this
interesting is that it's the first time
we see a creature from the upside down
outside during daylight hours it's also
a sunny day which should deter dart from
leaving the safety of the indoors maybe
it's a plot hole or maybe there's
something that makes dart special in
this stage three form you have the
esteemed privilege of being the first to
see my next form locked in the cellar
dart molts again stage four as we know
is the demidog demo dogs
demogorgon dogs
gamma dogs with a stronger set of claws
that come with this new form dart
manages to find a weak spot to dismantle
a corner of the wall once it reaches the
soil it's able to dig an escape channel
until it reaches the tunnel system all
underneath hawkins these tunnels are
used by the demi dogs to travel while
staying both out of the sun and the
public eye the best example of how
travel efficient these tunnels can be is
showcased when dustin and steve
harrington are joined by lucas and max
at the junkyard to help lure dart out
and take care of it dart appears after
the night has settled in and a fog has
rolled across the area but dart will not
fall for the same trick twice it doesn't
move towards the pile of meat that
they've set up steve believes that dark
wants a different kind of entree one
seasoned with faberge organics and steps
out of the reinforced bus to try to
provoke dart to go after him little does
he know dart is simply a decoy while the
other demidogs surround steve and the
bus for an ambush well well well
how the turntables
outnumbering steve the demidogs pounce
towards their next meal
stranger things heroes have changed a
lot over the years but that doesn't
change the fact that they started off as
a bunch of basement dwelling dungeons
and dragons fans they don't really cover
this in the show but you know at some
point they had to address the smell
that's why i'm partnering with scentbird
as the sponsor of today's video sunbird
is reimagining everything about the
experience of buying fragrances whether
you're just getting started with
fragrances or building your collection
sedbird acts as a place to express
yourself and discover your style sunbird
lets you choose a new designer fragrance
every month for just 17
every month you get to pick what you
want to receive so there are no
surprises they have perfumes colognes
and a lot of unisex options with each
fragrance you'll get a 30-day supply so
you can try out the fragrances without
committing to an expensive full-size
bottle but it goes beyond just sampling
different scents try their online quiz
to help you discover your elfactic
identity the scents i received this
month were sage supreme bentley
silverlake and commodity book i can see
why there's a reason people love the new
car smell it's very energizing has the
aura of cleanliness don't let yourself
smell like basement pizza make sure to
use my coupon code cz's world for 55 off
at sunburn.com it's just over seven
dollars for your first month available
in the usa and canada
[Laughter]
[Music]
inches away from the razor sharp claws
of a ferocious pack of dogs demi dogs
i'm sorry what i said uh demi dogs
like demogorgon and dogs like you put
them together it sounds pretty badass
inches away from the razor sharp claws
of a ferocious pack of demi-dogs steve
makes a run for it demi-dogs pounce at
him from all directions and one of them
ends up on the wrong end of steve's best
ryan sandberg impersonation we're in the
80s had to go for that 80s reference
steve gets to safety but one of the dogs
jumps onto the roof of the bus and
almost gets inside but gets distracted
by the call of another demidog or
possibly something greater more on that
later it's possible that this demo dog
on top of the bus was dart based on the
yellow spot seen on the tail but it's
hard to tell for sure if that is dark
maybe it took pity after seeing dustin
in the bus it joins the rest of the
hunting party and leaves to follow the
call of another one of its kind what we
can learn about this species from this
is that the demidogs hunt in packs like
lions and the raptors in jurassic park
once they have their target they lunge
forward teeth first like most of the
life forms in the upside down it would
appear that the demidogs are almost like
a remix of many creatures from our world
dart may have been called away because
of what was happening at the hawkins lab
where a group of scientists trying to
enter the upside down were massacred by
the path one demo dog appears from a
hole in the floor and tries to bash the
protective glass but unlike pennywise's
face that one time it fails to get
through so it lets out a wolf-like howl
inviting the others to join it this
signal is what lured dart and his party
away from the junkyard as a group
they're able to make some progress on
the glass barrier the entire pack of
demi-dogs invade the lab sending chief
hopper and a group of scientists running
for their lives as a pack they're able
to sync up their attack patterns for
example three of them tackling at once
is enough to rip down a steel door
allowing them to claim their prize and
chow down on a group of scientists
despite the fact that most of the
demidog's only exposure to the right
side up has been limited to the
underground tunnel network they still
seem to have no problem navigating the
halls of the hawkins lab earlier i
alluded to the demagogues sharing a hive
mind the term hivemind comes from a hive
of bumblebees the queen bee emits
specific hormones to help coordinate the
female workers and the male drones the
hive mind allows information about where
water or pollen is located to be shared
with the entire hive to make them more
efficient the damage dogs use a
combination of sounds to alert each
other and their queen is a colossal
creature known as the mind player the
mind player also has a special
connection with will essentially making
him a part of the hive mind by using
will to recognize where his friends were
located the mind player sent a group of
demidogs to hunt them down so mike has
the idea to sedate him to prevent him
from communicating with them as a result
of this the demidogs actually have to
search for their victims giving them all
time to move into the security room with
the entire lab taken over by demidogs
the group decides that they need to
perform a system reboot to reactivate
the door locks they send a man named bob
newby down to the breaker room he
arrives there and finds that every lab
employee in there has already been
ripped to shreds by the creatures he is
able to successfully restart the lab but
his friends find that he is now trapped
by a demidog that moved into the west
stairwell this in addition to the pack
using a decoy against steve harrington
earlier speaks to the intelligence of
these creatures they're not just like
bumblebee drones essentially following
orders and instinctually devouring prey
they seem to realize that the lights
going on means that there's somebody
back in the breaker room bob's able to
divert this dog using a noise created by
the sprinkler system and get away as the
others quietly move to the exit at this
point the pack splits up to more
effectively search the grounds which
leads him to getting caught he manages
to outrun one but its calls to the rest
of the pack allow them to quickly swarm
the door break it down and take bob as
their midnight snack they probably would
have been better off with the three
musketeers bar though
[Music]
chief hopper tries to shoot them down
but they're also bulletproof luckily
they're too engrossed in their meal to
care everyone regroups at the buyer's
house where they have their realization
about the hive mind and determined that
the best way to beat the army of
demidogs is to destroy the shadow
monster which acts as the brain of the
super organism they try to question will
in an ambiguous location but the mind
player is still able to find out where
they are and send the demo dogs their
way just as the first one shows up so
does the completely overpowered
psychokinetic girl 11. she snaps its
neck and tosses it through the buyer's
window for some reason that's actually
kind of rude i mean i hope she pays for
that the group splits up for a plan to
try to break the mind flare's influence
on will by closing the gates to the
upside down where a massive horde of
demidogs is now festering steve mike
dustin max and lucas stay at the house
after putting the dead demi dog in the
buyer's freezer for scientific purposes
you're explaining this mrs byers all
right they realize they can use the hive
mind to their advantage by creating a
distraction so that the dogs
so that the demi dogs are drawn away
from the lab thus creating an easier
path for eleven to get to the gates of
the upside down and destroy it or at
least close it they plan to do this by
starting a fire in the underground
tunnels using will's map they locate the
area where they think is the main hub
where all of the upside down tentacle
things are and cover it with gasoline
steve lights the area on fire which
causes a great deal of pain to those
tentacles and as a result every creature
that is part of the hive mind the demand
dogs at the gate all go crazy and the
mind flayer prioritizes putting a stop
to the fire so they all clear out of the
gate area steve and the kids run for the
exits but they come face to face with
none other than dart
start
[Music]
with the hub now on fire dart's newest
task was to take out any danger to the
pack by following the sounds of dustin's
group dart was the first to track them
down and face the boy who betrayed him
less than 36 hours ago let's just play
it back one more time
they slowly approach each other and the
two share a moment where dustin
apologizes for knocking dart into the
cellar and offers a three musketeers to
smooth things over and distract him long
enough for everyone else to sneak by
there are a couple notable things about
this scene the first is that the mind
flayer doesn't seem to have as much
control over dart as it has over the
others and dart is still able to make
decisions on his own the second is that
it almost seems like dart is wired
differently than the others having
developed a greater taste for chocolate
than it has for human flesh maybe dart
associates that taste with its youth the
same way that we always have a
preference for mom's home cooking in the
end dartanian chose to eat the three
musketeers rather than following the
mindflare's orders and in that sense he
lived up to his namesake from the three
musketeers novel one of the central
themes of the novel is this idea of all
for one versus one for all and dartanya
is forced to decide between being a
king's musketeer or part of his group of
friends known as the inseparables in
stranger things loyalty to the hive mind
represents the idea of one for all but
loyalty to his friend dustin who took
him in and fed him early on is an
example of all for one despite dustin's
repeated insistence that a demi dog is
not a dog their final meeting is
reminiscent of the saying goodbye to a
beloved pet trope demi dog or not start
was a good pet and friends to dustin
when eleven closes the gates the mind
flare is cut off from its house and dart
falls with the rest of the demidog army
with his army dead the mind flare is
forced to retreat but that doesn't mean
he's defeated but that's a story for
another episode of horror history
hopefully this analysis helps add some
context to the coordination of the demi
dogs and their life cycle and by the way
let me know who else you'd like to see
covered here on horror history or what
franchise you'd like to see me cover
check out that playlist on the left for
more stranger boys and remember to
subscribe to cz's world for new horrors
every week ring the death bell for
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survived
you